ah
[Música]
cuando era adulto joven no se hubiera
imaginado ser un presidente autoritario
un dictador para algunos de un país
diezmado y en parte destruido era va a
ser su hermano mayor quien debía suceder
a su padre hafez al asad
en los 80 diplomáticos occidentales
dicen haber discutido con él sin saber
que era el hijo del presidente de siria
bashar era un hombre discreto que quería
ser oftalmólogo y que estaba excluido de
la esfera política y de poder de su
padre pero un día de enero del 94 su
hermano basel el delfín brillante
colérico y violento muere en un
accidente de tráfico de camino al
aeropuerto bazar que estudia londres es
llamado de urgencia para volver al país
comienza su formación acelerada seis
años más tarde su padre hafez muere
también bashar al-assad toma el poder el
nuevo mandatario levanta o al menos
hacer como si levantara las
restricciones se instala una cierta
libertad de expresión pero es demasiado
para el nuevo presidente y la vieja
guardia que le rodea el grifo es cerrado
rápidamente y los opositores enviados a
la cárcel la primavera de damasco fue
efímera en el 2005 el asesinato del
primer ministro libanés rafic hariri es
imputado a siria y assad es marginado de
la comunidad internacional
a inicios del 2011 cuando estalla el
conflicto bayern estaba recuperando
viejas amistades tres meses antes había
sido visto en una brasería chic del
centro de parís se reunió con el
presidente nicolas sarkozy y posó para
la revista paris-match algunos días
después del inicio de la revolución una
reunión tuvo lugar en su domicilio todo
el clan se dio cita para definir la
respuesta a dar y la línea dura fue la
elegida no había que ceder ni un
centímetro el joven estudiante discreto
instalado en londres y fuera de la
política dejó lugar en pocos años a un
jefe de guerra despiadado su ex
vicepresidente abdel halim jadam aseguró
en el 2013 que asad es un hombre que
ladra paranoico que tiene personas que
prueban la comida antes que él para
evitar un envenenamiento los que lo
conocen tienen una imagen contradictoria
el mandatario se muestra muy seguro y
relajado frente a sus invitados para
demostrar que sigue teniendo al país
bajo control recibe a periodistas en una
casita en la colina que rodea a damasco
y el operativo de seguridad es casi
imperceptible lo mismo alrededor de su
domicilio propaganda pura aunque hasta
te reconoce algunos errores en la
gestión del conflicto nunca renegó del
método este año está preparando nuevas
elecciones para dar una apariencia
democrática todo es relativo a su poder